I saw one once was it it was so fluffy I
thought I was gonna die happy Mother's
Day
okay yeah we're fine are you sorry went
a little mama bear on you have a good
one from Despicable Me 3 pretty PG how
could you let Balthazar brats just get
away you're fired
he's really good to snuggle with Agnes
what are you doing since you don't have
a job I just wanted to help
ah excuse me Hey good you oh of course
now as I was saying I good my seriously
oh I really must have a word with you on
behalf of your twin brother drew why
twin brother hey brother
but I can't wait to meet my brother
[Music]
doesn't love this guy
look at him Alvin here would make you
better look at this face
why so mad you might see the beautiful
wife oh sweet talker
this place is amazing it's nice like
gasp you're I'm not really into things
basic groove you're losing blood the
guqin boobs you ready to continue the
family tradition you and me
no I left that life behind me just one
[Music]
I'm going in
[Music]
haha okay
this does not mean they're going back to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]